see that lady that got in trouble cuz
she shot a giraffe she shot it see yeah
she shot a rare giraffe and so
everybody's freaking out on her
it seems sad man that giraffe seemed
like it probably what was he gonna do to
her it's not gonna do anything to her
for sure it's it is rare for an animal
to get that old it's 18 years old it's
real dark yeah it had dark skin or
something a little yeah the old males
they get dark this is that super cool
one thing though that people need to
know see all these things are
complicated they're not as simple as
everybody wants to think they are and
this is one of the things that's
complicated about this store is that
that giraffe was killing little giraffes
it's a normal thing the old bulls like
that one which is a big massive 18 year
old animal okay a huge huge animal he
just was not having it with these young
ones coming up not having it what do you
think it is jealousy or anger it's just
nature
you know they kill off the younger males
oh yeah like pissed at the neighbor kids
kind of thing dude they just don't want
anybody taking their spot they don't
know that they're riding off from the
sunset he's not a viable breeding male
anymore I'm still huge so at 18 years of
age he had killed off three young Bulls
so they were gonna have to kill him
right cuz it's not good you need the
Bulls to keep the thing alive well it
was well not just that he this is a
species of giraffe that already has a
population problem there's not a lot of
them and if he's killing off these young
Bulls each one of those young Bulls
could have fathered countless children
yeah so they're missing all these future
children for one bull who can't even
breathe anymore and he's gonna continue
to do it he was seeking out the young
bulls you've already killed three like
this is not a cut and dry thing I don't
think it looks cool to pose with a rifle
and a giraffe and I mean there's
something about giraffes that are so
gentle that they let kids feed them when
you go to the [ __ ] zoo right I don't
so I get why people would be upset but
when you find out what it actually is
you go oh this is not it's this is more
complicated than I'm that I'm seeing on
the surface it's not simply a cruel
since shot a giraffe and we should be
angry at her right it's like now they
had to shoot that giraffe because it was
killing other giraffes
so is it appropriate the way she
celebrated it that's when you have to
wonder yeah but they were eating it mean
to see other things like they got
[ __ ] 800 pounds of meat or something
like that out of that Wow it's a huge
animal I think it was more than that
didn't they say 2,000 pounds of meat I
think it's a 4000 pound animal and they
got 2,000 pounds of meat which they give
to all the villages all the people there
and I know people are like hey I don't
give a [ __ ] you shouldn't shoot a draft
I feel the same way because when I see a
giraffe I don't think of it as something
I want to shoot and eat yeah I think of
it as something a little kid can feed at
the [ __ ] zoo because they're so
gentle they're so gentle that they like
people feed them oh yeah they had a
thing by our home when I was growing up
they had a thing do that a couple
giraffes out there a couple of lambs and
[ __ ] yeah get out there and buy a little
cup of corn and go out there and you
doing enough to know it like you don't
the sign a wave you have to do anything
you even have to [ __ ] be able to read
very well and you can [ __ ] feed a
giraffe you know point-blank it's the
only animal that is a wild African
animal that we let kids feed yeah at the
[ __ ] zoo little kids can feed him
yeah I can't believe that that is that
much I mean when I hear that for one the
lady what did she why did she have to
put that picture out what was in it for
her to do that it was she even knew like
she's a hunter and she was excited that
she got to kill a big giraffe you know
and the you know it gets its gets
strange when you just kill a bunch of
things and make stuff trophies and you
put them in your trophy room and you go
well I want to get it now I want to get
a ram okay I got a ram now I want to get
a mountain goat okay and you got with
this menagerie inside of your house yeah
that's it gets dark man now I want to
get a mouse now I want to get a stepdad
now I want to get it [ __ ] but then I
think it's like okay but if you're
eating all of those things and this is
how you get your meat yeah is that okay
well yeah it's okay but there's
something we did something we all have a
strange feeling about this the idea is
that people are killing these things and
they're getting some kind of pleasure
out of it and they're not doing it just
to eat it right it's not like even if
you you are gonna eat it we don't want
you to be really happy when you kill
something that's it - that's some of it
I think the villagers should
the ones that should vote on if it was
okay or not it's in their village they
would vote okay every time because they
get money from it then to me then that
seems okay because a lot of times it's
like we're judging things from so far
away we don't even know we don't even
know with like we're talking about
completely different dynamics in terms
of like the way their culture works
first of all the money for these big
hunts that these people pay to shoot all
these different things down there
that's a shitload of money and that
shitload of money for that area for that
part of the world is gigantic fuels
conservation efforts it pays for these
people that are essentially their
version of game wardens you know and
then they have these different people
that are employed by these hunting
companies and then there's resources to
stop poaching and then resources to
actively participate in controlling
habitat and making sure these animals
are in healthy populations and bringing
their numbers up this is all done
through the money that comes from
hunting so the super it's super [ __ ]
up right it's it's weird because it
doesn't make sense it's like the people
that are paying to keep these animal
alive are also the ones that want to
shoot them right people like what the
it's no we would like it to be all the
conservation money comes from people who
just love animals and want to keep them
alive but that's not the case that's not
the case no the money comes almost I
mean it's not exclusively because there
are a lot of conservation groups that do
donate for wildlife protection and for
preserving of animal habitats there are
there's there's definitely some people
that donate right but there's no it's
not even close to the amount of money
that's raised from hunting tag and
especially hunting you're on that local
level like you're you know like some of
these like these programs I'm sure there
are a little bit more bigger more
blanket you know but you get into that
local level fifty thousand dollars can
keep you know a small town or a small
habitat around for the year yeah you
know who's getting all that money but
you're right it's but it makes us
uncomfortable but rightly so I mean
you're looking at a giraffe you want
giraffes to stay alive you say like
that's amazing
but we have to know that the facts
behind it
this particular case were they that
giraffe had to go yeah